[Musica]
buonasera qualche giorno fa ho visto su
internet e una simulazione fatta da un
planetologo il cui nome ovviamente
impronunciabile non ripeterò quel nome
questo progetto ha progressivamente
sottratto da una carta geografica come
quella che vedete alle mie spalle ha
sotterrato progressivamente l'acqua
dagli oceani già a 5500 500 metri circa
il pianeta è praticamente un deserto in
questa situazione
sicuramente non ci sarebbe vita non ci
sarebbero pesci tutti quelli che come me
adorano andare sott'acqua sarebbero un
tantino irritati
ovviamente è una situazione abbastanza
inverosimile almeno nel medio periodo
difficile che l'acqua sparisca dagli
oceani ma è una condizione che ci fa
pensare è una condizione che ci fa
pensare agli enormi cambiamenti a cui
stiamo assistendo
nell'epoca in cui viviamo cambiamenti
climatici che comportano molti movimenti
soprattutto migrazioni migrazioni di
uomini migrazioni di capitali migrazioni
di pesci anche di piante abbiamo trovato
pesci palla di origini asiatiche nel
golfo di orosei
abbiamo trovato granchi blu di origini
americane nelle lagune del sarrabus
abbiamo trovato alghe killer che
soffocano le praterie di posidonia nelle
acque del sud sardegna sembra uno
scenario terrificante ma ci sono
meccanismi che portano i pesci le piante
a spostarsi nei mari questo succede da
sempre ma negli ultimi decenni sta
accadendo sempre di più
accanto a queste migrazioni ci sono
altrettante progressive sparizioni
sempre meno frequentemente troviamo nei
nostri fondali alcune specie come la
nacchera la pinna nobilis o il
cavalluccio marino si vedono
sempre meno frequentemente con questi
sono dei delle sparizioni che dipendono
sicuramente da fattori climatici da
fattori ambientali e dalla pressione
dell'uomo sul nostro ambiente
la pressione dell'uomo dipende dalla sua
attività dai gas serra che mettiamo
nell'atmosfera gli oceani sono
principali destinatari di questa
pressione
tenete conto che il cambiamento globale
ha comportato che negli ultimi 100 anni
circa il mondo intero globo terrestre
abbia registrato un incremento della
temperatura di in media di un grado che
è una quantità di calore impressionante
il 90 per cento di questa temperatura è
stata assorbita dagli oceani e quindi
gli oceani si trovano sotto pressione si
sono innalzati i livelli dei mari
il livello del mare negli ultimi 100
anni
si stima che sia stato di 20 centimetri
considerate che 20 centimetri sono una
dimensione molto rilevante per quelle
terre emerse che invece sono emerse di
pochi centimetri su quelle terenzi
strano popolazioni che se continua a
innalzarsi livello del mare potrebbero
trovarsi costrette a emigrare e quindi
nuovi movimenti di persone sono
sconvolgimenti che all'occhio nudo
diciamo di noi esseri umani sono poco
visibili ma stanno cadendo e quindi
dobbiamo riflettere su questi
cambiamenti sono cambiamenti globali che
è difficile affrontare a livello locale
ma qualcosa si deve pur fare vorrei
soffermarmi oggi sulle attività che si
svolgono in mare la nautica per esempio
o il turismo è anche la pesca la pesca e
il settore di cui vi parlerò oggi di cui
vorrei parlarvi oggi la pesca in europa
negli ultimi vent'anni e forte crisi sta
attraversando un periodo molto duro
le catture di pesce selvatico da parte
delle barche europee si è ridotta di
circa si sono ridotti di circa un terzo
lo stesso la stessa flotta ha subito un
decremento nel numero di imbarcazioni di
un terzo quindi c'è una forte evidenza
di un periodo di crisi
i pescatori non non vedono più
la pesca come un'attività redditizia
escono dal mercato
questa questa questa crisi si riflette
su una serie di avvenimenti in europa la
consistenza della flotta di circa 83
mila imbarcazioni di cui il 85 per cento
circa 70 mila barche sono di piccola
pesca che hanno un'età media di 24 anni
è una flotta abbastanza anziana l'europa
subisce molte pressioni da questo punto
di vista perché in altri in altre realtà
territoriali
l'imbarcazione invece sono più giovani e
quindi ci troviamo a subire una
pressione importante dal punto di vista
dell'efficienza della nostra flotta
tenete conto che l'europa produce il 3
per cento dell'intero prodotto ittico
del mondo mentre i paesi asiatici
detengono la quota maggioritaria il 70
per cento dei prodotti tc globali e
prodotto dai paesi asiatici
immaginate che solo tre paesi asiatici
producono oltre la metà della produzione
mondiale
capite bene che l'europa ha una
dimensione talmente piccola che è
difficile per una federazione di stati
poter incidere su politiche globali
quando si trova a che fare con dei
giganti di quel tipo
ma qualcosa bisogna fare allora l'europa
abbiamo detto ha una dimensione
relativamente limitata nel piano nel
panorama mondiale se ne pensiamo alla
sardegna ci chiediamo quanto pesa la
sardegna
ecco in sardegna abbiamo circa mille 300
imbarcazioni rappresentano circa l'uno e
mezzo della flotta della flotta europea
contiamo circa 630 imprese di pesca e
della pesca sono occupate più o meno
2.600 persone sono numeri molto piccoli
rispetto al resto dell'italia e
dell'europa e quindi
la ridotta dimensione al settore della
pesca denota già una sua fragilità
interna fragilità strutturale il settore
della pesca è un settore fragile è un
settore fragile dal punto di vista
strutturale quindi dai suoi numeri è un
dell'attività perché un settore
tradizionale che si basa sulla risorsa
naturale e se questa è una risorsa
naturale sotto pressione sotto pressione
a cascata sarà il il pescatore allora
questa vicenda porta ogni tanto i
pescatori a fare anche qualche battuta
un po sarcastica spesso io sento i
nostri pescatori che dicono i delfini
sono protetti dalle europee anche i
cormorani sono protetti ma a noi
pescatori che ci protegge se nessuno
protegge noi rischiamo di estinguerci
noi e quindi la popolazione non potrà
più mangiare pesce questa è una battuta
un po polemica anche se vogliamo da
parte pescatori ma ci fa intravedere il
segnale di crisi profonda
i pescatori sono delle persone
coraggiosissime che hanno sempre
adattato il loro modus operandi
all'ambiente sono stati sempre costretti
a diciamo da adattarsi al mare ea quello
che succedeva dentro il mare ma come
abbiamo detto negli ultimi anni la crisi
è stata talmente repentina e i
cambiamenti climatici e di mercato sono
stati talmente repentini che anche la
capacità di adattamento e ridotta cioè a
fa fatica a stare dietro alla questa
questo tumultuoso cambiamento allora lui
europea ha cercato di intercettare un po
questo momento di difficoltà ha dato ai
pescatori diversi strumenti uno fra
questi è costituito dal cosiddetto
sviluppo locale ha fatto un arcieri flag
to flag sono delle organizzazioni di
portatori di interesse cioè pescatori
comuni
autorità locali aree marine protette che
insieme si incontrano è assieme scrivono
strategie per un futuro possibile
strategia per un futuro possibile che
sono che compongono un bouquet diciamo
di azioni che cercano di ammortizzare
questi cambiamenti ammortizzare il colpo
di queste pressioni che vengono
dall'esterno
alcune di queste organizzazioni lavorano
con dei concetti di base con dei
concetti chiave che seguono che cercano
di seguire prima di tutto lo sviluppo
sostenibile delle aree di pesca sono due
parole che ricorrono in tutti i flavi
europei
in europa abbiamo circa 500 plug in
italia 5 una cinquantina in sardegna ce
ne sono quattro all'interno dei flavi
pescatori vengono ascoltati vengono
ascoltate le loro le loro preoccupazioni
vengono ascoltati i loro desideri e
insieme ai pescatori si scrivono dei
progetti per uscire dalla crisi o per
tentare di uscire dalla crisi
molti di questi progetti pescatori li
hanno già portati avanti sono idee che
già da tempo avevano il flag servi servi
a supportarli a sostenerli appunto a
fare in modo che quella capacità di
adattamento non venga meno non sia si
riduca nel tempo i flag lavorano ho
detto per lo sviluppo sostenibile
dell'area di pesca avendo sempre in
mente il concetto dell'innovazione
l'innovazione è una delle parole chiave
del di tutte le politiche europee
l'unione europea ci porta a proprio con
con grande trasporto verso l'innovazione
come concetto e in effetti quando
parliamo di azioni che i flag insieme ai
pescatori mettono in campo
parliamo spesso di innovazione
l'innovazione può avere diverse
dimensioni
una di queste dimensioni per esempio è
l'innovazione di prodotto e di processo
l'innovazione di processo in questo caso
dimostra un etichetta in sardegna in
particolare abbiamo una parcellizzazione
molto alta del settore della pesca ci
sono tante piccole imprese che
difficilmente riescono a collaborare fra
di loro ecco attraverso i flag
attraverso l'azione di queste
organizzazioni che aggregano stiamo
cercando di fare in modo che i pescatori
acquisiscano consapevolezza che stare
insieme è meglio e che assieme si
riescano a sfruttare economie di scala a
sfruttare diciamo a spuntare prezzi più
alti sul mercato proponendo dei prodotti
in maniera coordinata e magari
etichettando una cassetta di pesce con
un'etichetta evoluta che sappia
raccontare non solo delle informazioni
legate alla tracciabilità del pescato
quel sistema che ci permette di sapere
che un pesce è stato preso il giorno
hicks nella località y ma ci permette
anche di raccontare attraverso magari la
scansione di un più arcade
qual è la barca che ha pescato quel
pesce qual è il pescatore che tipo di
attrezzo è stato usato in quali mari è
stato prelevato il pesce anche come si
può cucinare anche dove lo si può
trovare in quale ristorante presso quale
pescheria presso quale rivenditore ecco
queste sono informazioni che aggiungono
valore ai prodotti della pesca e
riusciamo in questo modo a valorizzare
il prodotto a fargli avere magari un
prezzo un po più elevato magari anche
una redditività migliore per per il
pescatore
fra le altre innovazioni di processo che
immaginiamo futuribili perché ancora non
le stiamo realizzando mentre questo
progetto in via di realizzazione
fra le innovazioni dicevo futuribili
abbiamo pensato a come rendere più
efficiente il sistema logistico della
del trasporto del pescato voi immaginate
che tante piccole imprese di pesca
muovono ognuna il suo piccolo mezzo
questa è una cosa un po assurde in
effetti con i pescatori ci abbiamo
ragionato parecchio quindi uno dei
futuri possibili da questo punto di
vista per l'innovazione di processo e
immaginare un sistema di raccolta del
pesce un po come si fa per il latte poi
tutto sommato potrebbe essere
interessante capire se appunto esiste
questa possibilità per rendere più
efficiente il discorso un'altra
innovazione è quella di prodotto spesso
la pesca
diciamo si oppone o comunque in
contrasto con altri settori economici
spesso altri settori economici incidano
sulla pesca marina negativa qua ho fatto
due paragoni sono due località
turistiche il turismo più sostenibile e
un turismo meno sostenibile la pesca e
il turismo si integrano abbastanza bene
in certi momenti meno bene in altri
momenti
proviamo a parlare di momenti felici di
integrazione fra pesca e turismo per
esempio lagune aperte laguni aperte è
una una kermesse l'abbiamo chiamata così
è una futura possibile per lo sviluppo
delle aree lagunari è un futuro in cui
le persone arrivano nelle lagune in
queste imprese di pesca che possono
usufruire gli ambienti meravigliosi e
vedono cosa come la vorrei pescatore
come si comporta nei confronti
dell'ambiente che deve curare perché se
non cura quell'ambiente il domani non
avrà di che pescare e vengono realizzati
anche attività culturali attività
artistiche laboratori con i bambini
visite con mezzi sportivi con le canoe
con le mountain bike è un modo per far
fluire al turista dell'ambiente la
bonaria un'altra modalità di
integrazione fra il turismo e la pesca e
la cosiddetta pesca turismo attraverso
questa attività che i pescatori hanno
pensato da tempo ma che stiamo aiutando
a potenziare ea promozionate sempre di
più il turista può vivere una giornata
di pesca come se fosse un pescatore
questa è una cosa che sembra banale ma
non lo è in molti stati questa attività
non si può fare quindi in italia abbiamo
uno dei modelli più evoluti di questa
questo tipo di attività altre
innovazioni futuribili sui prodotti in
sardegna come abbiamo visto ci sono
tanti turisti e turisti spesso incidono
sulle aree costiere
molti di questi praticano attività
all'aria aperta ma attività sportive per
esempio il trekking l'arrampicata
sportiva la mountain bike
qui appunto ha cercato di esemplificare
qualcuno a pesca subacquea
abbiamo immaginato con i pescatori e
questo lo stiamo studiando di
rendere le barche da pesca parte di un
sistema di trasporto sulla costa per
ridurre gli impatti a terra e per
sfruttare comunque la dotazione
industriali che in alcuni momenti è
ferma cioè le barche dei pescatori
magari sì con dei motori elettrici
perché no altre innovazioni ci vengono
dall'economia circolare l'economia
circolare è uno dei settori diciamo in
cui si parla tanto ma come può arrivare
l'economia circolare nel settore della
pesca da alcuni drammi per esempio le
morie dei molluschi nelle lagune nascono
delle opportunità
lo vedrete come può nascere un
opportunità dalla dalla moria dei bonus
che bene i molluschi quando muoiono
devono essere smaltiti comunque stiamo
parlando di tonnellate di gusci di
molluschi un istituto scolastico insieme
a un flag ha pensato a questa cosa
perché non usare i gusci di molluschi
per triturare mischiarli insieme nelle
resine e creare dei manufatti che
possano essere utilizzati per le più
svariate e per i più svariati utilizzi
il per esempio dei banchi da cucina
occhiali e orologi si possono usare
questi materiali per qualsiasi cosa sono
riusciti a ottenere un materiale
ignifugo antiallergico atossico
un'innovazione di prodotto incredibile
innovazione di prodotto sempre per
l'economia circolare si può immaginare
questo è un futuribile di utilizzare gli
scarti della lavorazione del pescato o
comunque pesci che non vengono messi in
commercio sul mercato per produrre per
esempio biogas esistono le tecniche che
attraverso le dei biodigestori
enzimatici possono produrre gas metano
una cosa che fino a ieri sembrava quasi
impossibile invece oggi è possibile
farlo è possibile collocare nei porti
queste attrezzature e andare avanti con
la produzione di metano la
trasformazione dei prodotti a scarso
valore invece commerciale è comunque un
futuro attuale e futuro attuale dal
prodotto che non viene valorizzato sul
mercato il cui prezzo è abbastanza
relativamente basso vengono invece
prodotti dei trasformati che possono
essere
diciamo venduti sui mercati diversi che
esigono magari una polpetta di pesce
senza spina gli asili e mense degli
ospedali e così via
quindi ci sono diversi i futuri
possibili nel nel settore della pesca ne
abbiamo elencato alcuni l'ultima
immagine che vi propongo è questa vorrei
dirvi che la rete è una parola
estremamente utilizzata non bisogna fare
rete bisogna stare in rete ok chi più
dei pescatori può usare questa parola se
non loro
la rete nel mondo della pesca nel senso
che vi ho raccontato finora quella di
utilizzo di strumenti di sviluppo locale
quindi di organizzazioni che mettono
insieme le persone che fanno lavorare
insieme le fanno produrre fanno produrre
l'oro dei progetti delle vie d'uscita
per immaginare i futuri possibili
e proprio questo la rete per noi
significa creare comunità
innanzitutto creare occasioni di scambio
fra i pescatori di tutto il mondo perché
portiamo riusciamo a portare i pescatori
anche a vedere come funziona il settore
nel resto del mondo significa
integrazione integrazione dei pescatori
nella loro comunità e della comunità
all'interno delle imprese di pesca e
significa immaginare comunque un futuro
possibile migliore per stare a galla
come una rete da pesca
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]